نعم اهلا بك واهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه بالفعل وصلت قبل قليل سفينه جلاله
الملك الرياض السفينه العربيه التابعه
للقوات البحريه السعوديه قادمه من ميناء
بورتسودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
رصد قبل قليل على الرصيف البحري الخاص
بقاعده الملك فيصل البحريه وهي الرحله
الخامسه عشر منذ بدا عمليات الاجلاء من
ميناء بورد سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بجده نتحدث وعلامتنا هذه السفينه
200 وعشرون راكبا من خمسه جنسيات اذا
اخذنا التفاصيل هذه الجنسيات نتحدث عن مئه
وتسعه افراد من الجنسيه السودانيه و91 من
الجنسيه الامريكيه و14 السعوديه وثلاثه
كنديين واثنان من جنوب السودان وواحد من
الجنسيه اليمنيه كما نشاهد الان لحظات
قليله ويبدا تركيب السلم الخاص بالسفينه
جلاله الملك الرياض وكما ننون هذه الرحله
الخامسه عشر للقوات البحريه السعوديه منذ
بدا عمليات الاجلاء من ميناء بورت سودان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجد نتحدث
انه اعداد كبيره تصل بشكل يومي ايضا
المتوقع غدا وصول سفينه امانه سفينه
التجاريه السعوديه المدنيه وعلامتها اعداد
تلامس الالفين شخص من اختلف من مختلف
الجنسيات وهذه السفن المدنيه الكبرى
تستوعب اعداد كبيره من هؤلاء الرعايه
لاجلائهم من ميناء بورت سودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه ايضا لا تزال عمليه
الاجلاء مستمره عبر ميناء جدا الاسلامي
وكذلك الى قاعده الملك فيصل الجويه بجده
الان يتم استعداد لانزال هؤلاء الرعايه
ومن ثم استقبالهم من قبل سفراء والقناصل
لهؤلاء الدول لهؤلاء الرعايه لانهاء
اجراءاتهم من قبل السعوديه ومنحهم تاشيره
استثنائيه من قبل المديريه العامه
للجوازات لمده شهر حتى يتسنى لهؤلاء
الرعايه انهاء اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهم
لعودتهم الى بلدانهم في اقرب وقت ممكن
ايضا من متوقع ان يتم التعامل مع خمسه
حالات صحيه تم توفير مركبات الاسعاف هنا
في القاعده للتعامل مع هذه الحالات الطبيه
ايضا فيما يتعلق بالمقاعدين وذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه كذلك يتم توفير كراسي
متحركه لهم مراعاه لظروفهم الصحيه ايضا
ايضا فيما يتعلق بعبر مطار الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي بجده كان غدا غادرت خلال
يومين الماضيين وحتى مساء امس اكثر من
1409 مواطن هندي بعد ان تم اجلائهم من
السودان الى السعوديه وتحديدا الى مدينه
جده غادروا الى مدينه احمد اباد والى
مدينه كوتشين الهنديه ايضا نتحدث عن
مواطنين من الرعايه الصينيين كانوا قد
غادروا صباح اليوم عددهم
مواطن صيني بعد ان تم اجلاؤهم وقبلهم كذلك
347 مواطن صيني عمليات الاجلامي ميناء
بورت سوداني لقاعه الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده هي مستمره منذ بدا عمليات الاجلاء
وبدا النزاع المسلح بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني في السودان لذلك اعداد
كبيره من الرعايه بمختلف جنسيتهم في ميناء
بورت سوداني ينتظرون بشكل يومي عمليات
الاجلاء السعوديه التي تقوم باجلاء كافه
الرعايه بعد التنسيق من قبل وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه وكذلك
السلطات الاجنبيه للتعامل لاستقبال طلبات
الحكومات الاجنبيه
لاجلاء رعايه هؤلاء المواطنين الاجانب
نتحدث عن اعداد تجاوزت الخمسه الاف شخص من
100 جنسيه قامت سقوط السعوديه باجلائهم
منذ بدا عمليات الاجلاء في من ميناء بورت
سودان تحديدا لقاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
او حتى الى ميناء جده الاسلامي وعبر عده
الملك عبد الله الجويه لحظات بسيطه او
محدوده وسوف يقوم هؤلاء الرعايه والقوات
الخاصه التابعه البحريه السعوديه بانزالها
اولاء الرعايه بدءا بالسيدات واصحاب
الحالات الصحيه وكذلك كبار السلم ومن ثم
بقيه الركاب هذا البروتوكول متبع على كافه
السفن البحريه السعوديه العسكريه التي
تقوم بالوصول او ان ترسي او ترسى هنا في
قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه بجده المتوقع
خلال الساعات القادمه وصول سفينه
الدمام الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
وعلامتها عدد من الرعايه بمختلف الجنسيات
وكذلك عمليات الاجلاء مستمره من السودان
طوال الايام الماضيه وكذلك من المتوقع ان
تزداد الاعداد بشكل كبير جدا خلال الايام
القادمه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات